à la fin du mois de janvier 2021 une
équipe d'enquêteurs de l'om s est arrivé
en chine avec pour objectif de retracer
l'origine du virus reste qu'au vu de
leurs résultats sont très attendus
cette enquête s'est fait sous fond de
tensions internationales alors que
plusieurs pays accusent la chine de
manquer de transparence sur les débuts
de la pandémie mais la science
nécessaires pour répondre à ce genre de
question prend du temps parfois des
années et au delà de la politique
comprendre l'origine de la pandémie est
essentielle si on veut éviter qu'un tel
événement ne se reproduise dans l'avenir
où et quand la pandémie at-elle commencé
c'est une question beaucoup plus
complexe qu'on pourrait le croire les
premiers cap de kobe 19 sont apparus
dans la ville de wuhan en chine en
décembre 2019
dès janvier 2020 les caméras du monde se
sont braqués vers le fameux what market
de la ville de wuhan d'où seraient
prévenus plusieurs des premiers cas de
la maladie
avec le temps on a remarqué que d'autres
de ses premiers cols n'avait jamais été
en contact avec le fameux marché
d'autres études génétiques ont suggéré
que le virus circule est même déjà en
dehors de la ville de wuhan en décembre
même si ces études ont encore besoin
d'être confirmé on comprend donc que
même si le virus ont recommencé à se
propager dans la ville de wuhan serait
pas nécessairement dire qu'il y est
apparue la piste la plus probable pour
expliquer le début de la pandémie serait
quand même celle d'un animal sauvage qui
serait retrouvé dans le fameux marché de
one ne sait pas encore exactement de
quel type d'animal il s'agit d'autre
hypothèse suggère que le virus serait
arrivée à oran grâce à des produits
surgelés mais c'est une hypothèse qui
demande encore à être confirmée
finalement certaines personnes suggèrent
même que le virus pourraient s'être
échappés d'un laboratoire dans la ville
de wuhan
mais jusqu'à maintenant cette hypothèse
est considérée comme hautement
improbable on qu'on voit donc qu'il
reste beaucoup de travail à faire pour
démêler toutes les possibilités sur
l'origine de cette pandémie
le virus peut-il avoir été conçu en
laboratoire malgré l'incertitude sur
l'origine du virus
les chercheurs restent convaincus qu'il
est apparu de façon naturelle dès le
mois de mars 2020 une étude parue dans
le journal nature à confirmer cette
intuition en montrant que la structure
du virus n'était pas un assemblage de
fragments de virus déjà connu chez les
humains chaque on aurait pu s'attendre
s'ils avaient été créés en laboratoire
dont la structure du virus sras skov 2
est plutôt composée d'éléments provenant
de virus animaux et d'autres qui ont dû
évoluer par sélection naturelle pour
éventuellement pouvoir infecter les
humains cela exclut donc la possibilité
qu'il a été créé de toutes pièces
que sait-on de l'origine du virus la
principale hypothèse est que ce virus
est apparu dans une population animale
probablement la chauve souris avant
d'avoir fait son passage à l'être humain
on a d'ailleurs retrouvé un corps un
navire russe similaire à 96% au virus de
la kfw 19 chez une espèce de chauve
souris en chine mais une différence de 4
% dont on parle de génétique ça reste
énorme
en plus il manqué à ce virus sauvage un
des éléments clés de la coved 19 la
protéine est ce ça c'est les petits pics
pour trouver la surface du virus et qui
lui permettent de s'accrocher aux
cellules humaines pour acquérir cette
information manquante le virus a donc dû
passer par un autre animal qu'on appelle
un autre intermédiaire on pensait
initialement que cet animal aurait pu
être le pangolin un des mammifères les
plus braconné de la planète mais les
virus qu'on a retrouvé chez ce dernier
sont trop différents de la cave et 19
pour qu'ils aient pu jouer ce rôle
d'autres manient faire sont parmi la
liste des suspects parmi lesquels par
exemple on ne les visons ou les furets
mais il n'y a pas encore de réponse
définitive trouvé cet animal
intermédiaire reste donc un des plus
grands défis des enquêteurs
pourquoi cette enquête est elle
importante plus d'un an après
l'apparition du virus ce genre d'
enquête veut surtout nous aider à nous
préparer à la prochaine pandémie et avec
l'origine animale comme principal
suspect toute notre attention devrait se
tourner vers notre rapport à
l'environnement
depuis les 20 dernières années les
chercheurs ont remarqué qu'il y avait
une accélération du rythme de
transmission des virus entre l'animal et
l'humain on appelle ce genre de
transmission des zones aux et pour les
chercheurs cette accélération pourrait
être dû à la destruction de
l'environnement en bouleversant les
écosystèmes les humains entre de plus en
plus souvent en contact avec des animaux
qui se tiennent normalement l'ont aidé
nous et avec ses contacts viennent une
hausse du risque de la transmission de
virus inconnu donc mieux comprendre les
liens entre les animaux et les humains
qui pourraient être à l'origine de cette
pandémie
ça pourrait mettre en lumière certains
éléments aux facteurs de risque dans
notre façon d'exploiter l'environnement
et favoriser des modes de vie qui
pourrait ensuite réduire ces risques